[Music]
welcome back to ask
the expert
that's got to be a shirt
so we have benny lou here who is the
founder and ceo of
next shark which is the leading
publication for asian american
news thank you for being here
thank you thank you thank you so you
guys if you missed the previous episode
he answered a whole bunch of amazing
questions but we have more questions
here that you guys have asked
so let's just jump right into it let's
do it all right
first question here is what's a piece of
advice you were told
and regret not putting into practice
earlier or not taken seriously enough
earlier in your career
oh sex before marriage
that's a really good one huh should have
[ __ ] way earlier
oh man now i forgot the question you
guys are just describing
sex like some some advice someone has
given you and then you were like i wish
i took this [ __ ] earlier when i was told
yeah you regret not taking it i think
this is a very specific
specific one but this is the first one
to pop into my head is that um i think
that
um you know i i learned very early on
that there's a difference between like
being a bootstrap entrepreneur that's
you know just you know kind of starting
out compared to like a funded you know
entrepreneur and so
you know i came from you know when i
when i was diving into entrepreneurship
more
and i was really like inspired by like
the social network at the time and like
you know
wow this is crazy this guy's like you
know building these uh
multi-billion or billion dollar tech
companies without having any revenue or
whatever i'm like damn
that's that's crazy and so i had this
thought where it's like okay you know i
just gotta
you know build it don't focus on money
let's just focus on you know uh
meeting justin timberlake give you money
yeah exactly exactly right
and so i mean uh so i just had this
belief of you know trying to
um and that was the school of thought
right but then you know i had some
friends that you know
went no you got to focus on trying to
figure out how to bring money in
you know earlier yeah because the first
version people are
some people will say that's unethical
because there are there's a group of
people that would
that there's a school of thought where
it's like yo you're basically a snake
oil salesman you're inflating a product
selling it off it has no value has no
income but it is a strategy it is one of
many strategies
but there are it's a school of thought
in investing and all that where people
think that's
wrong to do yeah yeah so i mean again
two different schools of thought i mean
if you do raise funding for you for your
for your company i mean you know
the upside is you have now a [ __ ] ton of
money in your bank account um you know
but obviously the downside
there's a level of downside too is that
you know a lot of the times you have to
spend that money as quickly as possible
to you know get that sort of you know
growth right and i think that
um for me i think if i could have done
it differently i think i wish that i
thought
uh more about um you know how i could
monetize
a little bit earlier especially since i
didn't have that padding and so i'm
definitely learning now i mean you know
i
i'm trying to find more and more
opportunities to you know
find ways to monetize and to be a little
bit more you know focused on roi if that
makes sense and you know it's something
i have to do i mean
and in the grand scheme of things i mean
if i'm trying to be idealistic i'm in
order for me to help my workers and to
make sure that they're taken care of i
need to
also make sure that the company is
bringing money at the same time too so
um and for the people that that's out
there that don't know how tech companies
are like
these silicon valley companies work and
with startups
it's like the strategy is either
get bought out or funded by someone else
who believes in you
or whatever or you're just a
self-sustaining business and what
benny's talking about
is like you can quote unquote i don't
want to i don't know if
latin is the right word i don't know
what other word to use is like you just
make it
look really good for maybe an investor
or a buyer to come along
to pay for the business expenses or
fund benny's project for a million
dollars or maybe a billion right
and that is a strategy that is used
to make this business work but if you
don't find any buyers you can't sustain
that business
yeah if and in most techno tech
companies
if they don't have funding there's no
income coming in
so you run out of the supply of being
able to pay your team
interesting yeah so it's mainly uh
monetizing for you yeah
monetization monetizing or finding a
model of monetization early on yeah
being able to sustain in-house without
injections of
outside people yes yeah that was really
just kind of the
kind of the main thing i mean you know i
i mean i can always find things
that i can regret but i try to live life
in the most positive way
but if i could think of one thing it's
probably that one yeah it's pretty good
so how about
on the flip side here this question asks
er when you be
when you began your journey as a
businessman
what advice stuck with you the most and
was pivotal in making you into the
person you are now
oh that's such a it's a loaded question
i have to think back i don't know if
it's like one specific thing i mean
why are people always looking for like
one aha moment that changes your life
forever and then like they
like it's gonna never i think that's
just human nature right really
because look when you get to know
someone that's like what's your favorite
food
or whatever it's like always like the
way i see it is like i don't want to
bust a knot one time i want to bust a
knot every night for the rest of my life
so so like i don't know why do you think
diet pills exist
true it's easier to comprehend i guess
yeah
yeah it is a diet pill of for like
like advice right yeah that makes sense
it's like aha thank you
yep right yeah i think that for me it
was just that um
i think it was just the old uh the the
old
advice of if at first you don't cc just
try try again
and um you know i think that the one
thing that i'd have to kind of give my
mom credit for
was and she's a very strong woman you're
like the only thing the only one
everything else man i gotta give her
okay okay in terms of this in the
context of business and stuff like that
right is that
you know she worked a lot like you know
girl i mean i think that i feel like my
work ethic comes from her because even
because i uh you know what did she do
for a living she was working she was
actually
um a business reporter and worked at a
chinese newspaper for a little bit so
it's interesting
it's interesting that i'm in this
business right now yeah i know right
yeah so
so she was actually in the she was in
the business but she was a type where
you know uh
she you know she she came here from you
know china to san francisco in the
in the mid 1980s with my dad they didn't
have you know typical i had 50
in my pocket and you know and so in the
mornings in the daytime they would you
know
uh work at the chinese restaurants as
dishwashers or as cleaners and
you know some ends and then cooking and
then at night um they would take the bus
all the way across town to attend uh
english classes
and then i swear i feel like they're
inflating some [ __ ] details here like
at night and then we had to go two hours
to the
exactly exactly right yeah exactly i
went with my mom to
adult school so she could learn english
i know i was making jokes
i think no they're talking about like no
i had to work it was like maybe it was
one mile but really don't know it was 10
miles you know
how big was the fish you caught and it's
like oh this big
yeah it gets bigger and bigger as time
goes on exactly
i went down to los angeles every night
yeah so you know they and so you know
they would get home and you know that's
what they told
me at 12 and they started all over again
you know and so um and they would they
worked hard growing up and so i never
really saw my parents as i was growing
up my grandma raised me and so
you know they just worked hard as as
time went on and so
i think you know for me it's it's just
that i mean
i i know i know generally where my
destination is and i'm going to do
whatever i can again where is it
beverly hills beverly hills yeah yeah
exactly
i don't know yet actually it's just more
like you know i i still don't know what
that
place yet but i know that general you
know how i want to feel when i'm that
place
is that i want to be in a place where
you know people are proud of my work
they felt that i have
given back in a good way and they've
also and
i've and i can feel like you know
somewhat you know proud of my own work
for the impact that i've made for
for for people ahead of me and so you
know when it's all said and done i don't
want people to think of me as oh he made
a bunch of money or he made certain
things i want them to feel that hey i
and
i you know had a hand in you know maybe
inspiring the next generation and doing
you know bigger and better than i ever
will you know i mean at the end of the
day like that's
you know especially in the context of
immigrants and being people of color
and everything right i mean we have so
many people you know before us that
paved the way for us in so many
different industries
you know um and so i think that
us even here today whatever we're doing
i think that no matter what we're trying
to do
no matter you know how rich you want to
get or how successful we want to be
you know i i think that there is a level
of responsibility for us to keep paving
the way forward and to keep like you
know and to be
that good example for you know the
future generations to follow so that
you know again we want to leave the
world better than when we found it right
and i think that's the mantra that i
think we should all
live by i used to tell people pursue
your dreams and then i was like but
i don't want you to compete with me so
[ __ ] it don't do it what's your dream
it's too similar now you know that's
another thing too i think that
would you want to be a oh you want to be
a doctor okay [ __ ] it yeah i need an
audience
oh man you know yeah for me like
especially like with like in you know
especially
with asian americans i feel like a lot
of us like try to compete against each
other a lot and i come from that
school of thought where it's like look
you know you can be in the same industry
as me it's cool i prefer to you know
us to if i'm building a building like
gary vaynerchuk says if i'm building a
building
i want you to i want us to compete
building higher around us
not to tear everyone everything around
us you know
yeah i feel like we've been lucky in the
asian-american
kind of like entertainment group
because especially maybe this is
different like
for actors or people competing over the
same role
i i feel like there's more infighting in
different
places right but for us as youtubers or
like digital guys like
it made more sense to collaborate
because we can share
audiences and there was so much love and
then like i would hear
other communities go through their drama
and i'm like whoa i'm [ __ ] glad man
there's nothing but
like like collaborations non-stop here
that was the golden year of the youtube
years right i call them the girls
there's like hella new asian kids that
it's disjointed like we don't know who
they are they don't know who we are
whatever right
but when we were all kind of in the
early 2000s man that was or like late
2010 or something like that um
that [ __ ] was dope like we all knew each
other i wish that
i i i missed the days where i could just
call up you know joe or bart whoever
here and be like hey let's do a collab
video and that will be it
right yeah now it's kind of like i gotta
call this person up oh wait no let's
talk to my manager manager gotta talk to
the asian and
everyone blew up yeah yeah yeah it's
it's you know those are the golden years
man i really felt that there was like a
community there
i'll tell you a secret i am my own
manager
[Laughter]
they all blew up but we're still the
same so what's your manager's name
ralphie
not even ralph ralphie he's cute
all right ralphie schwartz um
so what was your first job ever and what
experiences and knowledge did it give
you
my first job ever was i think i was
either 11 or 12
and um you know i was you know my my
parents were working next door and there
was like a sandwich shop
you know next door to them and i would
go to them to work and so with
my parents permission and everything i i
started working as a cashier sandwich
maker at the cyber cafe
yeah it was it was it was interesting it
was cool you know 11 12 how cute yeah
i made 650 now 650 6.50 an hour plus
tips
and uh it was during those times when
you know this was like maybe like in the
you didn't need like a workers permit or
something it was like it was something
along the lines of that you know it was
probably under the table of some sort
but they had there was an agreement with
my parents i mean we were close
we were all close family friends already
so it was pretty much as good as just
working for like almost like a family
member of anything you know but
it was interesting at the time there was
like uh um
it was it was a cyber cafe so people
would just come in and just use the
internet
and and stuff so it was uh it was
interesting times i mean i
saw some weird customers at the time i
mean i think i caught somebody watching
porn on a computer once it was like yeah
why did you confront them and be like yo
man it was dude can you imagine
i'm like freaking i'm like i'm like and
i'm just like
seriously is that what's really
happening right now you were watching it
no i was like i i i you're 10 11 you're
watching
it was like the screen was right here
and then like the head was right there
so i was just like uh
i don't you know it was hiding i could i
knew
what it was but i didn't i didn't see
all the details i bring my blanket
because i like to keep the computer warm
okay
can you see the shadow of them because
of the light and then
did you see that kid in the [ __ ]
airplane video he had a blanket
and then he had the window open so the
window had a silhouette
and then he had the airplane bacon on
and you see nothing but pow pow pow pow
yeah wow who's going at it
i'm jet lagged
oh my god so yeah what experience
knowledge did you gain from that first
job
um i think that uh learning how to deal
with
our dirty yeah learning how to deal with
inpatient customers learning how to deal
with
you telling me shut up weird people
early on you know seriously like when
you when you're put in that sort of
situation
and and everything you just meet you
meet a lot of interesting people that's
for sure i relate because one of my
first jobs was also at a cyber cafe yeah
it was in mexico i was 15.
yeah and yeah like totally deal with
catching a weird stuff happening like i
didn't i did
i did catch people watching porn and
yeah there was even this one instance
where
this lady she comes in she because it's
in mexico and speaking spanish
she didn't know that i could speak
english and so she was talking [ __ ]
about me
in front of me in english oh my god i
was like excuse me and she was like oh
wait outside
oh damn yeah it's just like yeah it's
just learning how
how people are yeah the things that
people do in public that are shameless
i'm like damn okay if you want to be
happy for the rest of your life
do not become a leader and do not run a
business
i think the best words of advice to her
was like hey do you have any like words
of wisdom for people looking to get into
business it's like yeah
yeah if you need words of wisdom if you
need words of wisdom then don't do it
you're not you're not in
you know i love how like when we go to
like colleges and stuff people go like
what
you know what what kind of advice would
you give for someone who wants to start
a business and i'm like
okay all this step-by-step [ __ ] you
could learn on google of how to open up
a business
like what kind of papers you need done
whatever that shit's the easy part
understanding yourself emotional control
social skills by far
the [ __ ] best tools you can ever have
as a human being like just in general
even if you're not a business owner but
i think specifically if you want to run
because it's a people like art like at
the top levels of everything even as
engineers or whatever right like
at that point you're managing people
you're not doing the work like like you
might
like even if you're inventing [ __ ]
you're managing like the staff
that's helping you do the nitty-gritty
so you got to have really good people
skills
and i would i think that's the that
that's just my take on it yeah i think
that i mean
the way you guys even i mean i don't
know too many details how you guys run
jk news or something but i like the way
you guys do it and it's kind of it's
similar to how i you know look at things
in next shark too i think that
often times like especially with big
companies now like they kind of reduce
all their workers down to a number like
you know people don't know each other
and everything
like for me like i make a concerted
effort to know everybody within my
company and i want to know them on
a personal level because like they're
they're they're the small pieces that
make make my company work you know
without them like you know i'd be
nothing you know
so um i think that uh and i think i see
you guys too i mean you guys all hang
out together you guys you know you guys
take care of your own and i think that
at the end of the day i don't want to be
all cliche and be like oh we're a big
one big family you know everybody always
like you know
it's a different style to me it's like
global
corporation versus mom and pop like
we're not a mid-sized company we're a
mom and pop like it's a family business
right so like
huh
but like it's it's it's like a like
that's the difference it's like a family
farm family business
versus like a multinational corporation
they're going to act different
an institution is going to be very
different compared to
there's way more like quote-unquote
professionalism right
yeah well there's more variables dude
yeah how do you
how do you determine how big your
company is like
employees there is like what determines
something as a mid-sized company is i
think anything
around 100 or plus employees right
anything under that is a small business
i think it's but then you can look at it
that way or you look at it
revenue size but you can have like two
three partners and make
billions in revenue i don't know but
like i think it depends
where does next shark stand in terms of
not revenue but like
employee sex oh we're small we're small
business for sure i mean i think we have
like maybe
i think we have less than 10 full-time
employees but we are hiring more at the
moment trying to hire more
yes you know as we as we go um yeah we
keep it in the family i mean we have uh
we we have a team in the us but we also
have like people in europe we also have
people in asia too so it's like
it's kind of like a 24 hour operation so
international
yeah it's cool because like we have this
like you know we have writers that we
never even met before but they've been
with us for like five years like more
than five years so like we we're very
close it's just that we haven't had a
chance to really
spell the funny way like c-o-l-o-u-r to
see how old you are now
spell correctly dumbass
what is that a british spelling of color
i know right we spelled it wrong right
yeah i think we spoke
there's always a fight between the
british british english and u.s american
english you know it's always that fight
that's true no but i'm happy to keep it
small i mean i i like the fact that i
know
everybody um in my company um and it i
feel like as
the downside to running a big company is
like as it gets bigger you kind of just
naturally start losing that control
because you only have so much bandwidth
as a
as one person you know and you kind of
have to start entrusting people and so i
think
how i look at it is that you know i see
everybody
on my team potential as a potential
leader down the line and i want to see
i i want this experi their experience
you know when they work with me to be a
really
good one they feel like they're
developing themselves like their skills
as they kind of
you know move forward and hopefully if
we do get to that you know area i have a
very good foundation and continue
like you know scaling i mean all big
companies were won small companies
that's true like
you know google started in a garage
that's true so like
facebook too so yeah but then i don't
want to get i mean
it's funny because i always wonder like
do i want to get that big you know once
because like
at some level it's kind of like you know
i think yeah
now the way that i determine success is
like okay
the ferraris the cars yeah aside from
that
like like the like the concept of
winning and what you want right so it's
like
everyone can win but do they can they
stomach it
it's like to get there do you know what
it takes do you know the sacrifice you
have to make
and then i think in the early stages
when you don't know the sacrifices that
you have to make everyone wants to be
number one
because they see like kobe or they see
like nike or they see these big ass
corporations and jeff bezels or whatever
right and you go damn
that's insane right and then you
actually see what they did to get there
and you're like
do i want that maybe i'm okay with just
a million
i can live a great life maybe i don't
have to do that you know i don't know
i think that it's also important to ask
yourself it's like you know what is it
you know like what do you want yeah what
do you want because like you know
something a lot of people say they want
money they want like you know wealth you
know why though especially if you're
young
but you have to understand why why like
you know most i think i believe that
most people want money because like what
does it give you it gives you choice it
gives you freedom yep
those are the two fundamental things and
it's just that money is just that here's
tell me what you think about this okay i
think that
most people that
are telling you these things it's all
to make their anxiety and fears go away
validation or yeah validation
yeah so like it's like i want what they
got because their life looks better than
mine
right that's one or they look important
they look loved
i want that that's true or like um
if you look at the root of it it's like
i want attention because i never had
attention as a kid
so i want to be a star or like
very rarely do people obsess and care so
[ __ ] much about their craft to the
point where they want to share that with
the world
that's like a vehicle to their actual
pain yeah
i think that's true yeah yeah yeah and
then because i remember i was like yeah
i want to make [ __ ] tons of money and i
was like why
oh because it was the root of my anxiety
as a child because my parents never
had it or like we were always having
bill collectors call the house so i'm
like i always want to make i'm not going
to be like them
where they're always in debt i'm like
i'm going to be different i'm going to
make a ton
because it was like that was my answer
to it and when i hear people go i want
to make a lot of money
i'm like i know where that comes from
it's because
you you don't want to suffer that's all
it is you're cursed like me joe you're
you're going to live life with always
something to prove that's how we live
there
yeah he's like we always have to yeah i
don't want things i don't give a [ __ ]
about things it's like i want this
feeling to go away
yeah all right benny next question here
uh what were your daily habits when you
were starting your business to get where
you are now
and have they changed you jack off every
day at least
so stressful gotta check off a [ __ ]
uh it's like that a wolf of wall street
scene is like are you jerk you jerk off
oh you gotta pump those numbers
that's just how stressful you know wall
street is nowadays
oh man i think for me it's like man i
think i never really
i feel like for me every day is kind of
different i mean even right now every
day is different because like i'm just
looking at what problems do i have to
solve today
and you know and and i solve them and i
think that i'm still trying to get into
a routine and now that i'm i'm going to
become a father now right i have to
figure out a way to get into a routine i
can't just like have random
you know i can't just be you know
sleeping at 5 a.m one day and then you
know waking up at 6 a.m another day for
something else like i kind of have to
get a routine down as i as i kind of go
but
i think in in back then i was just
desperate to try to make it i was just
trying to find every way to do it and so
i wasn't thinking about
i think this is a weakness of mine is
that i'm not a very structured person
i just kind of see like you know if i
see something i just go and you know
let's say the analogy is just like
redlining every day like you would get
to a point where like okay i'm just
now it's time to sleep and the next day
red line again now it's time to rest and
then so it's just every day that's kind
of like inconsistent
yeah and also because i have really
really bad insomnia so i've never really
like have been um it's just been really
tough for me i just have really bad
insomnia and so
for me it's just always like uh until
like i started taking melatonin at night
that kind of you know that that helps me
sleep a little bit
um i would just like wait until i i just
keep working until i just feel i can't
even open my eyes anymore it's fine i'll
just like you know fall asleep back
back there so man yeah those days were
crazy i still remember when i first like
you know
the early years of you know dating you
know my girlfriend now my wife is that
um you know we
my apartment used to be a mattress on
the floor you know so
you know i was just so every day just
focus on work i didn't even care about
the things that were you know really
around me
and stuff like that and um you know it
was just go
and the analogy i always use is like you
know that
mostly represents how i look at things
like if all of us agree to build a house
right then you know we all say okay you
know bart you can you know start drawing
up the blueprints and then geo you work
at the foundation and then somebody
handle the cement i'm already laying
down bricks
you know i don't even you know like
without knowing where that is and so
i think that a weakness of mine is i
lack that structure and that's what i'm
trying to fix in myself right now
it's that you know it's good to you know
take action and go go go
but you know you got to have that
balance too of making sure that
you plan properly it's almost like you
know what you said it's like
you got to make sure your car is good
before you know as you go otherwise like
you know you're fixing it on the way
there which is gonna make make it a lot
harder
so and do you feel like for yourself
you've actually ended up having
a lot of those lessons come back to you
because of the fact that you weren't so
structured
like there were moments where you're
like damn i should have my own back
i mean it's hard to say i mean you know
it's hard to say like when things happen
and i think that how i look at it as um
you know there could maybe i could have
made better decisions and i could always
analyze it but i look at it as
you know this is what you know this this
i guess this is
what life like put me through and
um you know there's positives and
negatives you know of how i ended up
today and that's kind of how
you know i look at it have you ever
considered teaming up with someone with
that
strength that comes naturally to them or
hiring someone or
i do but trust is a big big thing for me
like for me like i don't why you're very
like i need to build a skill on my own
kind of yeah i think i don't know where
like the lack of trust i mean for me
i don't open up to people like that
easily and you know and and for me like
i keep to myself like most of the time
you're not lazy enough is what it is
because laziness is like
yeah bro i'm like yo man filmmaking is
oh it's tough let's find somebody
you know like it's like yo man i don't
want to [ __ ] host jk news
[Music]
like can somebody go and talk to these
people and kind of socialize
can you bring these new guests in and
i'm like cool i could share my pie i
don't give a [ __ ]
like how bad can they really [ __ ] me
over
you know yeah see we're the opposite
like for me it's like i didn't know how
to write so i learned to write i
didn't yeah you developed the skill well
i'm immediately like
oh that's too much work somebody help me
somebody help me i think those are the
habits i think that's it
like where where you're interested in
something and instead of just kind of
going like oh [ __ ]
um what do i do you're like okay i'm
gonna lean into it i'm gonna lean into
it i'm gonna learn how to do it on my
own and
um when do you know when to stop like in
a day like is it when the task is done
or is it when you're like i'm [ __ ]
exhausted that's it
yeah i'm learning that lesson with my
wife actually because like that you're
you get exhausted father yells at your
ass no no she because she's like you
know because i i feel bad because like
sometimes it's kind of like you know i'm
working and then next thing you know
like she's knocking on doors like hey i
know you're working but it's 9 p.m
and you haven't eaten anything all day
and you should dude that's so
considerate what a
what a cool partner been like yo
where's my where's some i haven't had
any dick in a week what the [ __ ] i would
have been a horrible wife for you she's
like yo you haven't ate honey like are
you okay
oh yeah you did a ball job yeah
he's like no man this [ __ ] is dry homie
like you just been in that room like
god you weren't a woman dude
you make the scariest woman ever no bro
this pussy's right
dawg what about to get some dick around
here like what are you gonna dig me down
so we moved in i thought i was gonna get
plenty of dick
what the [ __ ] you're out here working
till 9
30. work on this body god damn it oh man
so yeah i mean i'm trying
i'm trying and so i think that it's like
now i'm just kind of like
there comes a time when it's kind of
like it's almost like driving a car you
know how far it's going to get there
but i'm just still driving and like you
know but
i don't i need to realize that hey like
it takes time to
you can't go across the country in like
one drive you gotta be like rest stops
and
yeah so i don't really know when to rest
yet and so
you know i don't know i'll literally
like be working and then you know
without drinking like
i've gone like you know seven eight
hours without like drinking
any water you're just really good at um
tapping into the zone man oh yeah yeah
you're just good at flowing
but then it's like the avatar when
you're too much into it is going to make
you sick
yeah yeah and so yeah you gotta control
the flow or else you'll burn out like
and have some
hell of uh health problems i think
that's what happens yeah you know it's
crazy i've gone to the place where it
gets scary sometimes and i think i want
to caution anyone getting into business
too because like don't
don't follow my path either because i
think that it's gotten to the point
where
um it's funny like i sometimes i don't
even know when i'm when i'm stressed out
like you know that feeling when you work
for so long and like you know you're
stressing you know you're tired but like
somehow like
the disconnect between mind and body man
like you know
you should work with the camel back
just have it to you at least
hydrate yourself at least my friend and
the chinese foot massagers
so at least you're like constantly
getting de-stressed yeah yeah
i do i do have like a foot massage like
a shiatsu foot massager and yeah i just
have it and so you know sometimes i'll
be attending meetings i was like okay
this is relaxing this is good
this is cool all right so the last
question i have here which is kind of
you've touched on a little bit is what
does your average workload slash workday
look like as
the ceo of next charge pre and current
state and covid oh wait wait the last
part is what uh
it's like a second part to the question
which is pre and current state and code
okay um i think that in terms of like i
just got more busier nowadays because
like you know reporting a lot on you
know crimes against asian americans
and the rising asian american rhetoric
right um rising anti-asian rhetoric
and so um i think that it's working by
the way i was watching uh
just like regular cable tv and like
these stories that are like you know
a lot of my fault like i'll be repost
next shark or a bunch of other asian
avenues and then
um a lot of like the non-asian followers
would be like oh my god i don't know
this [ __ ] has happened this is [ __ ]
crazy right
yeah and then we're like yeah it's been
happening and it's cool that like
there's
places like next show that's getting it
out there that it's finally even on like
regular tv and i was watching regular tv
and they're reporting it i'm like yes
it's working
just mention something about it too
first presidential speech
yeah nice so i mean i mean honestly it's
just
it all started because of next shark uh
asians with attitudes
uh uh asian there's another
god i'm gonna jackfruit also jackfruit
oh yes
and uh you know there's been a lot of
great uh you know local reporters too
like safon
there was like you know dion dion lamb
she's been really amazing too
um i also got to give shout outs like
daniel day cam daniel will and lisa lane
oh they did that oh listening is right
yeah they brought me on to they brought
me onto this clubhouse and um you know
and i i felt the smallest person in the
room but they basically like you know
lifted me up
they they gave next shark like such a
big like shout out like
i mean i you know i get it like there's
been a lot of people like you know in
the ground floor
volunteers have been doing this work for
a while but like you know again like
these guys have big big platforms and
you know and
so celebrities like not just asian
american celebrities celebrities in
general like they
tend to avoid like topics like this and
the fact that you know they're coming
out and they're speaking out using their
platform to kind of amplify things
forward like that i think that you know
i'm grateful for that
yeah i i think it's cool because it's
like a unified effort
between all of us like just trying to
get that word out to keep
you know our elders and everybody safe
just know like oh [ __ ] this is happening
so
you know watch your back yeah it's
beautiful too in a sense to see i mean
it sucks obviously it sucks to see like
what is happening but it's cool to see
like the community
really working hard to try to come
together on on some level and i think
that
this is something that you know hats
have been done at some point yeah
and so i mean hopefully i think that
we're moving in the right direction i
mean of course shit's still happening i
mean i don't you know obviously no one
can guarantee that hate crimes and stuff
are gonna stop but
you know let's just try to keep it
together the thing is once
the public has a view on it then the
law enforcement is there they have to do
something about it because they're like
oh [ __ ] we look bad
because we're not you know people and
the corporations and the media like
they're
they're getting pressure now to you know
really talk about it and to acknowledge
it and to find using their resource and
their capital to try to help out too
because
it is an issue you know so with all with
the the peak and um
you know anti-asian i guess sentiment
that's been going on and
making you more busy like what does that
week look like versus
you know at the beginning of kovid
versus before kobit
so i think nothing has changed except
for me getting busier however like my
day is very sporadic i mean
it's funny because i feel like uh i
think some of my teamers don't think i
sleep
because like for me it's kind of like we
have a we have like a
our own like global dedicated like slack
channel for everybody on the team and
like we have like different group chats
like we
we we share memes with each other and
stuff and and all and everything and
i'm checking at it all the time even
when i go up go up in the middle of the
night to use the restroom and stuff like
i'm on it i'm on it talking to you know
trying to
just checking in and stuff so it's
almost like i'm conditioned to just like
i'm conditioned to check in like pretty
much like all the time and so
which is something i'm trying to fix too
about myself but it's funny because like
they're like wow i think
benny seems to be just always awake like
i see him checking in at
sometimes at 3 a.m sometimes at you know
5 a.m sometimes middle of the day or
during work days and stuff
um i think that it's like i i find time
to rest and then once i feel like i've
gotten
a rest and it's just you know you wake
up the same time every day or every
day's different
different i mean sometimes like you know
even this week right so like for example
i try to wake up by like you know 8 or 9
a.m every day like consistently but
my schedule's just sporadic so sometimes
like let's say on wednesday i had to you
know get up early for an interview in
the east coast east coast time so i had
to get up around like you know i think i
got up at 5am
around that time and so i slept early
then to catch up with my sleep but then
there was another time when you know
uh you know neck sharks where i had to
work there was a tech issue with neck
shark and so i had to like you know work
around
work like throughout the night with our
web developers until up until like 4 or
5 a.m in the morning and obviously there
i fell asleep
around that time so uh and so yeah it's
still
very very sporadic and i think a big
part of my time right now
is um i think what's different in terms
of like my duties is that i
i've taken myself away more from the day
to day at next shark and i'm just and
more of it is like kind of like a lot of
meetings and
a lot of is just checking up on the team
and i'm actually finding a lot of value
and you know just doing one-on-ones with
your team members because you know just
to see how they're doing just to show
that you kind of care and you know just
just to you know just shoot the [ __ ]
with them um because like you know
what's happening right now it's kind of
tough to report on all these news
it must be pretty draining just as a
viewer like to constantly open up my
instagram
and then i see like you know some
violent [ __ ] and then i see some butt
cheeks to relax me
and then there's a cute little puppy and
again there's some like hate crime thing
going on and i'm like yo man that shit's
[ __ ] with my heart
i'm starting to get horny off of this
[ __ ] and that's not that should have
happened
it's like yo this girl looks good in his
bikini and then next it's like
oh my god the horror and then i'm like
we gotta do something about this and i'm
a [ __ ] piss and i'm like if i see
these [ __ ] on the street i'ma [ __ ]
beat their ass
and then i [ __ ] go oh my god is that
a deer oh it's a deer in the [ __ ]
winter forest that is so cute right
but the thing is i think that
just as a viewer it's kind of so
shocking just
being on your end with people submitting
countless amounts of footage
and all you guys see is non-stop elders
getting beat
people getting hurt whatever crimes
robberies whatever right doesn't that do
something to your psyche because i know
for our hosts when they have to
filter through the news when there is a
negative
uh kind of season where there is a trend
right everyone's all into murders this
year or whatever like
or like there's a trend of like oh
there's a lot of hate crimes right
it takes a toll on that psyche because
you think that's the whole world but
yeah
how do you guys deal with that
psychologically yeah that's a very good
question
so i think that first of all to
acknowledge you i think that you're
you're the opposite of how how like i'm
feeling i'm just feeling freaking numb
about all this for you you don't even
know
what to feel anymore because so many
things are approaching you or just like
you're just it's just like you're so
desensitized because of
how often it it for me personally it's
it's
desensitized because i've been doing
this for like i mean we we covered hate
crimes
before this right but obviously in terms
of the rise in hate crimes it's been
over a year now you know
and uh and a lot of the times is that
you gotta look at it this way so
it went from maybe one to two news tips
a week to up to 50 a day
wow yeah news tips and stuff like that
now granted like you know
there was a lot that was like you know
like maybe you know different people
10 different people will submit a report
for the same thing right but still it's
still concerning in a sense right
of like you know of you know more so
many people submitting like incidents
reports and everything
so um and a lot often times like you
know
because we have to review these footages
like we can't just like be like oh yeah
this happens we're posted we have to
actually vet it
and we have to talk to the people
involved and everything and sometimes
like
it involves like viewing a lot of
distressing footage and we get trolls
man we've gotten like
you know people people just sending us
videos of somebody beating up other
people like to a pulp
literally you know and like yeah like
you know like we got a video of like you
know a house breaking without any
context of like a jet of a gentleman
beating a
beating a woman and you could hear you
could hear like you know
like you could hear like bones like you
know crap like just really bad like just
like they just do it because they want a
scary [ __ ] with you guys i don't know
what they want to do
we just get a lot of like you guys do
get a lot of [ __ ] trolls man
like fake racist accounts just you don't
know
like they're just fake ass accounts that
are just [ __ ] with
your community the the commenters you
guys like
it's pretty bad it is it is and you know
some and you know it's uh it's tough and
so now like
you're dealing you're dealing with that
and then my staff members i mean they
you know
they're not only having to deal with the
emotional toll of vetting these stories
and reviewing distressing
footage they're also dealing with you
know uh their own cyber bullying
themselves online
they're also dealing with death threats
and stuff you know you know for me like
as an organization we believe in
supporting other minority communities
and so you know we
we we took a position of supporting the
blm movement when that happened and you
know and so
uh you know during that time like yeah
we you know we got we got like some
death threats we got like you know a lot
of like you know
we got doxxed some of our you know we've
got dogs too it was it was
it was pretty bad and so it got to the
point where you know
i've had to you know give my workers
mental health breaks
and i've had to um you know
uh get everyone together and do like a
session for everyone like a therapy
session because i need it too it's not
just them you know i freaking need it
from all the stuff that i
that i view and and you know for me like
i'm on the ground floor with these guys
so even though like i don't do the day
to day like i
i do my best to experience what my
workers experience every day and that
involves like just being observing
what's happening
seeing the types of stories that they're
vetting and um and just seeing generally
what's going on so it
affects me too and so you know i saw it
from early on you know and so
um you know we did our first like you
know mental health session you know full
company-wide i think it was like you
know
i think it was like back in march or
april or something and you know from
from there i think what's really keeping
us together is number one like you know
us we keep each other together because
we we talk we talk to each other all the
time
we're always constantly keeping up with
the you know keeping you know just
making sure everybody's okay
and then another thing is supporters
like we do have a lot of supporters that
you know send us nice
information send us nice notes too so
you know the balance
yeah no there's a good balance between
the two but sometimes like you know you
know how the world is people you know
sometimes like the
the negatives outshine the positives
it's just the way it is you know how do
you do the company-wide therapy thing
you bring in like a
therapist yeah you bring either bring
like a therapist or you bring in
somebody that you know that that has
done this sort of work before to
you know to uh just talk to the team i
mean i wouldn't say it's like an
official official therapy session but
just all of us getting together just
talking about what's going
on like how are you feeling yeah how are
you feeling right now you know like you
know you know
like does that therapist feel gang
banged after they're smoking a cigarette
in their car like
you're like [ __ ] usually i talk to one
person i got [ __ ] 10 people luckily
the person that we
that helped us like they volunteered to
help us out and we we've been very lucky
like we've had like you know actual
like licensed like hiatus therapist like
offer up their time be like hey if you
got if you need anything
you let me know so we have that we have
that in the back burner but
you know i think for the most part like
how i look at it as you know what you do
you
if you guys if you if you guys need a
break for any reason whatsoever just let
us know
we'll take well you know we'll figure
out a way to take care of you um if
you're feeling at any point that this
work is too much
then you know then um yeah just let me
know and it goes along with their
followers too i don't know if you saw
that uh post we did
so like literally like i think it was
like four weeks ago like we wrote like a
post to our audience on instagram and we
were like hey
you know hate crimes against you know
asian americans are rising and
oftentimes like uh
you know are you're probably going to
see a lot of you know distressing stuff
on our account and we know that the
emotional toll that could bring to you
guys how so
if you guys need to unfollow us or even
like you know mute us for a while we
totally understand like you know we're
not going to take it personally
and so and you know surprisingly you
know people people like were really
it got really well received and stuff
too and so um we're trying to be
cognizant of everything that's happening
so
you know i don't want to make it seem
like um you know i think some trolls
that criticize
oh you know you're trying to like you
know profit off of like you know all
these i was like dude like no we don't
have fun doing this
and let's put it this way how many
brands do you guys know of
at this point would you know it's not
like i can sell ads against like this
you know what i mean like you know
sponsored by whoever you know like
a man dies on the street after getting
beat sponsored by
jumping you know like you know it's like
you know so
it's like you know we're not we're not
doing it for the money we don't really
care
so much about the clout in fact like we
want people we want people more people
to get involved like we're not activists
you know we can only
you know we can we all all we can do is
do what we do best and try to present
the facts and the stories as is in the
most responsible way possible
we don't get 100 right all the time but
we do our best to you know work hard and
we're just human just like everyone else
you know and
and all of us i mean even with you guys
at jk news like you guys just want to
know what's going on in the world you
know
and and try to make sense of it because
there's so much noise right now you know
and you don't know what's real you don't
know what's false anymore it takes a big
toll
that's true man well i think that
it's awesome putting a face to the brand
because i know that you know we have a
lot of crossover fans who follow neck
shark's instagram account
and um a lot of the times when i follow
like accounts like
i'm so used to seeing like meme accounts
right or just
pictures or like pictures and captions
and they don't realize that there's
humans behind these videos and they have
to filter and all that so like
you know it's pretty cool that now
there's someone in the flesh
that can represent neck shark and they
can see that
because it's like guys like all of these
things require
human beings to like you know deal with
and
sometimes i think that's why it attracts
so many [ __ ] up
people to it or like angry people or
whatever because it's like
they don't know that there's a human
being that they're hurting behind there
yeah and i think that also like i think
it's easy to say that
you know and i and it's really easy to
kind of see me and it's like oh i'm
trying to prop myself up as like voice
of asian americans in the context of
next shark and
that's not the case i think that you
know i look at it as our community is
made up of so many different types of
people
right and and you know i am i am east
asian and i have a certain background
that i was raised with that
many many other people that identify as
asian americans that don't that don't
like align with you know it's not it's
not the same experience never want to be
a role model and represent
i talk about rim jobs for a living you
know what i mean so like if people like
you got to be a good role model it's
like there's an audience for that it's
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
foreign